it took nearly 20 years of parliamentary
debates and concessions to commercialize
nigeria's oil company
the government hopes the new firm will
attract private investors and cut waste
and corruption
we are transforming our petroleum
industry
to strengthen its capacity
and market the relevance
for the present and future global energy
priorities
leading the transformation is an
industry veteran
this company can make quick decisions
can invest quickly can borrow quickly
can pay back loans when they do and also
but most importantly to be accountable
to shareholders
the oil and gas sector reforms come as
global attention move towards cleaner
energy
with proven reserves of 206 trillion
cubic feet of gas and hoping to grow
that to 600 trillion
official expectations here
are understandably high
for a country
so blessed in gas like ours
we cannot
be happier
and
more excited
but concerns remain
many here are worried that the era of
cheap oil they are used to will soon be
over
in the absence of these
workers or refineries we import this
thing
and
if you import it
hide and
and to be honest there's a limit i don't
see i don't see how government can
continue with this subsidy in nigeria
at about 40 cents per liter nigerians
pay less for petrol than almost anyone
else in the world critics say subsidies
have stifled growth and bred corruption
now with private investors coming in
nigerians may have to pay more for fuel
the new company wants to offer shares
for sale as early as next year it's hard
to say whether this commercial venture
will go the way previous privatized
companies would struggle with assets
tripping and corruption or will prove to
be an exception
muhammad idris al-jazeera abuja nigeria